time for today's bar chart is the
plunging oil price showing up at the
pump how long can I hold that silence
for for dramatic effect it all depends
if you live in Europe or the United
States now this chart Compares gasoline
petrol it's what we call it here in
England in Europe and the United States
since Brent oil Brent crude oil began a
42% collapse on June the 19th so June
the 19th is the beginning of this chart
the purple line is BR crude as I've said
it's Fallen 42% since the end of June
back on that date it peaked at
$115 71 so that's the purple line since
June European gasoline prices the yellow
line the line at the top have fallen by
8% just 8% that's according to European
commission data in the US pump prices
have dropped more than three times as
much
27% that's according to data by the
American Automobile Association that's
the green line that's us pump prices the
other line by the way the red line is
European gasoline excluding tax which
shows a drop of 16% over the period now
olly Hansen who's head of commodity
strategy at saxo Bank in Copenhagen he
sums it up absolutely perfectly he says
roughly 2third of the price we pay in
Europe at the pump is tax so no not much
joy for European drivers so far he goes
on to say that changes in European pump
prices are smaller than movements in
crude oil because of the scale of the
continent's taxes and the fact that most
are levied at an outright level rather
than at a percentage of price so here
are the figures tax on gasoline in
Europe is about $4 a barrel according to
European commission data in the US taxes
amount to about 49 cents a gallon
according to API data so there you go
the oil right is a the oil decline to to
to use such a to use such a phrase is a
distant dream for European
drivers